welcome to let's play amnesia oh I
forgot what it's called la casa it's a
DLC and you won't see my face because I
just woke up and I don't feel like
putting clothes on so yeah let's start a
new gang
I guess oh oh cool riding the oversight
in South Africa I made my skin crawl
with goosebumps and my heart race
remember as the ones who save humanity
from all illness all disorders
[ __ ] this is so cool I'm so excited
there's like so many oh that's a gayest
voice
his hair was greased back in his suit
was quite snazzy
he was obviously there's my three he
told me that he knew public advisor to
you and I had begun my quarter stare out
what I'm at the University he then went
to great detail explaining how he
stumbled upon it while attending college
and found that we were onto something
our research for a cure-all medication
closer to completion we could ever have
expected he then went on to explain that
we are only missing one chemical in our
experiment called it Sian tight as he
produced a small vial
our team has found a source of cyanide
and said it can be extracted in great
quantities but they need more scientists
and a dinner they need scientists for a
scientist to manage who am i picking out
his freakin accent but yeah anyway I'm
excited to play all these there's so
what is this I can't pick it up there's
so many freaking customs things that I
want to play and I want to get scared
it's awesome the newspaper is brown and
worn cure all at all possible today to
sign this alba jones and eugene crowley
are researching a new pharmacy that will
treat all ailments from the common cold
car broker the two have been nominated
no peace prize how awesome good for day
them I'm guessing the writing isn't it
as fine polish but it's okay I honestly
didn't get much
get all the way Oh a start I'm so happy
now
look stop bunny okay whatever let's stop
oh the starter I forgot about you
let's go on the shirt exit I expected
the trees and bugs but I didn't expect
the plane's engine to fare I can only
remember oh this is pretty cool
ah my head make it stop
get up
stop [ __ ] cops oh that was a sweet
huh
that's how I get up when I'm passed out
whoop okay so let's go this and we have
oil instantly sweet then have that in
just seen freakin shitty okay so yes
that's where we crashed and someone set
up a camp fire for us
I almost missed my Adam and Byron now
mum okay so who knows what's lurking in
the darkness let's take it real easy
whoa whoa whoa whoa whoa whoa whoa what
the balls
okay loading screen I ran for what I
felt like miles and completed before car
coming to a small clearing I like that
it's centered - good job anyway
I'm coming [ __ ] let's go here
which way oh how convenient what the
[ __ ]
it's whoa
I wonder if darkness works in this game
or if the lantern is just there for you
no let's follow these I guess
and then i'll only thing the telus
feelings being watch something i
couldn't shake but then my hope for
rescue was renew when i saw lights you
already seen the light so what are you
[ __ ] talking about left alright how
many freaking even walk it if you can
walk in holy [ __ ] temple back entrance
what's the other way then
a note from search entry 34 dr. G
Griezmann it's been a week since we
arrived at the site our contractor mr.
blue seems to have forgotten it's the
balloon Sam was being held by the other
doctors have made a report some unusual
noises coming from the depths I assured
him there was nothing but the wind I too
heard these sounds though
this place gives me the creeps I just
want to finish gathering this chemical
leave as soon as possible
alright let's gather the scientists I
mean huh Peters what the I did not
expect the [ __ ] monster what the [ __ ]
is going on I don't see [ __ ] oh my god I
guess he went into the temple Oh coughs
so let's follow him with the 360
I mean 720 I guess [ __ ] I can't do it I
had no choice I followed that
monstrosity into the into some unknown
Dave's wide exactly then I have no
choice
oh [ __ ] ah this looks very bad
well
oh Jesus Christ
I'm in a tinderboxes 3 nope
suffer this place
alright what's down there
actually I'm not gonna find out right
now at least probably some node over
here I'm so smart Astro bar 388 dr. G
Freedman the team was right sounds were
warning that we did not heat it we just
set up after reaching a rich source of
cyanide why are they like a bottomless
wouldn't miss a stuff on them we called
further on the radio but got nothing
back soon enough Lewis our geologist
found missing during the search no we're
about leaving us with only myself dr.
kleiner and dr. wing came back to the
main chamber of this place after much
discussion we decided to board the main
hall wait three days for the missing
team members to make their way back to
camp and if they do not show we will
return to mr. blue one of these thing
bye-bye
okay so there was nothing here benzene
oh yeah I got a crowbar now so I guess I
can dare put her over here
wait swim no problem
crowbar I release
[ __ ] yeah I'll oh how I put it on one
and all of them disappeared still makes
no sense where the monster went he's
pretty acrobatic if he got passed laughs
or maybe set him up
okay let's check here and maybe there's
something underneath
no they just put the [ __ ] search
there good oh I'll just loading these
halls were visited before myself I was
comforting the conclusion of pathways
today was unsetting though I can see
that
I should say them
hello
okay sweet
who set up this thing oh you're so
delicious whoa whoa whoa whoa whoa whoa
whoa whoa why pigs [ __ ] pigs man oh
my god they they tortured the big no
mole they tortured the big
oh that's nice
apples
legs oh wait what is that
[Music]
and now the tinderbox
all right sweet
who made this mess geez
whoa
whoa whoa well actually never mind I
thought
it's kinda creepy hello beauty your
outside to this temple but I know our
way out
you just got to do everything I spurn
okay let's go to the waterworks I guess
these halls were visited before myself
that was comforting the conclusion oh
I'll reread that
doesn't work oh this looks
yeah
what are we doing down here where's the
sign more stuff I think that Oh oil
sweet
we get all out of order laughs thanks
let's go here what is this and hear it
over here but maybe it's not
[ __ ] lot what about this oh it's
locked too
well what
basta bad whoa look at this it's a bug
okay whatever then Jesus Christ what's
this
you